Zahlreiche Nachrichten-Portale berichten über
den Asteroiden mit der Kennung 2018 LF16,
bezeichnen ihn als “Monstrum” mit “gigantischem
Ausmaß”, der mit “rasanter Geschwindigkeit”
durchs All eilt.
Demnach könnte er die Erde schon in vier
Jahren treffen und ein Massensterben auslösen.
Was wissen wir über diesen Asteroiden und
was ist wirklich dran an dieser Horror-Meldung?
Die Antworten bekommt ihr jetzt hier: Herzlich
willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschaftsnews.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen: Es soll ein “gigantischer
Mega-Asteroid” sein, der laut einigen News-Seiten
Kurs auf die Erde nimmt.
Und nicht nur das: Den Meldungen zufolge soll
die NASA sogar ein mögliches Datum für seinen
Einschlag auf die Erde genannt haben.
Konkret geht es um den Asteroiden mit der
Kennung 2018 LF16, der mit einem Durchmesser
von rund 200 Meter knapp doppelt so groß
sein soll wie Londons Uhr-Turm “Big Ben”.
Entdeckt wurde der Asteroid im Juni 2018.
Wir berichten ja hier bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction immer mal wieder über Asteroiden,
von denen manche tatsächlich eine Gefahr
für die Erde und das Leben auf ihr darstellen
könnten.
Denn wir sind ständig bedroht von Kollisionen
mit erdnahen Asteroiden.
Viele Objekte sind klein und verglühen in
der Atmosphäre, ohne dass wir es bemerken.
Doch manchmal dringen Himmelskörper auch
in die Atmosphäre ein.
Und das kann fatale Folgen haben: Fliegende
Trümmer, Tsunami-Wellen und schlimme Erdbeben
etwa könnten einen Großteil des Lebens auf
der Erde auslöschen.
Hollywood-Filme zu solch einem Worst-Case-Szenario
gibt es genügend.
Aber auch erdnahe Asteroiden, die weniger
als einen Kilometer Durchmesser haben, können
uns gefährlich werden.
Denn von ihnen sind nur wenige bekannt. 2013
schlug solch ein unbekannter Asteroid in der
Nähe des Uralgebirge in Tscheljabinsk ein.
Obwohl er nur einen Durchmesser von 20 Metern
und ein Gewicht von etwa 16.000 Tonnen hatte,
wurden 1500 Menschen verletzt und 700 Gebäude
wurden beschädigt.
Für solch ein Szenario oder eben deutlich
schlimmer könnte laut einiger Nachrichtenportale
eben auch der Asteroid 2018 LF16 auf der Erde
sorgen.
Es sind tatsächlich Meldungen, die seit einiger
Zeit im Netz herum gehen, die Panik verbreiten
könnten.
Denn hier werden sogar mögliche Daten für
einen Einschlag auf der Erde genannt.
Schon am 8.
August 2023, also in rund vier Jahren, könnte
es soweit sein.
Oder aber am 3.
August 2024 und als ein weiteres mögliches
Einschlagsdatum des “Monstrums” so die
Meldungen wird dann außerdem auch noch der
1.
August 2025 genannt.
Zudem ist von 62 verschiedenen Flugbahnen
die Rede, die alle Kurs auf die Erde nehmen
bzw. die sich mit der Erdumlaufbahn kreuzen
könnten.
Das alles basiert den Meldungen zufolge auf
Angaben der NASA.
Schauen wir uns das mal genau an: Fangen wir
mit der Geschwindigkeit des Asteroiden an:
Auf der offiziellen Website der NASA kann
man in einer Tabelle alle Charakteristika
von 2018 LF16 nachlesen.
Demnach ist er mit 15 Kilometern pro Sekunde
im All unterwegs, was für Asteroiden durchaus
normal ist.
Das ist also keineswegs besonders schnell,
so wie es oft zu lesen ist.
Auch was die 62 potentiellen Flugbahnen mit
Kurs auf unseren Planeten angeht, sollte man
etwas genauer hinschauen.
Denn auch hier wird mit Blick auf die NASA-Tabelle
deutlich, was gemeint ist.
Hier listet die US-Bundesbehörde für die
nächsten 100 Jahre 62 nahe Begegnungen zwischen
Erde und dem Asteroiden 2018 LF16 auf.
Da es sich um einen erdnahen Asteroiden handelt,
ist auch das keineswegs besonders besorgniserregend.
Denn erdnahe Asteroiden ziehen nunmal in der
Nähe der Erde ihre Bahn.
Die eben zitierten Termine im August 2023,
2024 und 2025 stammen ebenfalls aus dieser
NASA-Tabelle.
Hierbei handelt es sich aber um nicht mehr
als die ersten drei Daten der insgesamt 62
Vorbeiflüge, von denen ich eben gesprochen
habe.
Für jeden der gelisteten Vorbeiflüge wird
auch eine theoretische Kollisions-Wahrscheinlichkeit
genannt.
Doch auch hier wird wieder deutlich: Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist jetzt nicht extrem hoch, wenn nicht sogar
niedrig.
Denn sie liegt bei dem ersten Termin im Jahr
2023 bei 1 zu 370 Millionen.
Für August 2024 sogar bei 1 zu 480 Millionen
und im Jahr 2025 liegt die theoretische Kollisionswahrscheinlichkeit
des Asteroiden mit unserer Erde bei 1 zu 1,2
Milliarden.
Wenn man alle 62 Vorbeiflüge und deren entsprechenden
einzelnen Wahrscheinlichkeiten zusammen addiert,
beträgt sie 1 zu 30 Millionen.
Anders gesagt: Damit ist eine Kollision mit
der Erde mit einer sehr großen Wahrscheinlichkeit
AUSGESCHLOSSEN.
Natürlich muss man an dieser Stelle auch
festhalten, dass die Bahn des Asteroiden noch
nicht ganz exakt vorauszusagen ist.
Dennoch ist es überhauptnicht nicht angebracht,
dass der Asteroid 2018 LF16 irgendjemand schlaflose
Nächte bereiten sollte.
Denn laut NASA-Datenbank hat er eine Palermo-Zahl
von knapp minus 6.
Diese Palermo-Zahl ist ein Maß, um Asteroiden
nach ihrer Gefährlichkeit einzustufen.
Grob gesagt wird es ab einer Zahl kritisch,
die deutlich über 0 liegt.
Klar ist auch, dass NASA, ESA undsoweiter
ab einer Zahl von minus 2 wohl etwas genauer
hinsehen Und dazu kommt: Mit einem Durchmesser
von etwa 200 Metern ist er schon groß, aber
keinesfalls gigantisch oder gar ein “Monstrum”.
FALLS er die Erde also doch treffen würde,
könnte dies für die Einschlags-Region durchaus
dramatische Folgen haben.
Doch ein Massensterben oder gar einen Weltuntergang
kann ich ausschließen.
Denn das steht fest: 2018 LF16 gehört zu
den kleineren Asteroiden, die wir kennen.
Also Entwarnung, was aber nicht heißt, dass
Asteroiden ein ziemlich unkalkulierbares Risiko
sind.
Und sie können mehrere Kilometer groß sein.
Das wäre eine Katastrophe.
Ständig schlagen auf der Erde welche ein
und beim Tunguskaereignis oder dem Einschlag
in Tsjeljabinsk haben wir immer Glück gehabt.
Das muss nicht so bleiben und wir müssen
einem großen Einschlag unbedingt vorbeugen.
Wie groß die Gefahr ist erfahrt ihr in diesem
Video: Asteroiden bedrohen die Erde - jederzeit.
Pflichtvideo, für alle die sich dafür interessieren
also unbedingt draufklicken.
- Ansonsten: Bis dann, bleibt dran.